This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode.
in today's episode in honor of the new year and, you know, the ambitions a lot of us probably hold for 20, 26, we're going to be taking a look at success, specifically the very intricate, fascinating psychology behind success. Now, this is a topic that I've actually, I've shied away from this for a little while. I feel a little bit weird talking about it sometimes. I feel weird talking about success and ambition so outwardly and I often have this assumption that it's going to make me appear shallow or egotistical or arrogant. You know, if I were to acknowledge my own desire for success or acknowledge what it means to work for success, the psychology of it. But the fact is, what I've come to realize is being successful is a huge human desire and it's intertwined
with a lot of other major human desires. Our need to strive, our need to strive, our need for purpose and that doesn't mean everyone's version of success is going to look the same. Mine might be different to yours, but whatever it is, the psychology behind what pushes us to be ambitious and to want more for ourselves is so intriguing. And that is exactly what I want to break down today. What defines success? What maybe determines success in some people and not in others? And essentially, how can we use the psychology?
and we use the principles and the research to be super clear on our own version of success and the behaviors, the habits, the actions that might get us closer to that. So I'm excited for this episode. There is a lot of research packed into this short episode. Let's get into it. Firstly, I want to talk about what we actually mean by this concept of success, just breaking it down a little bit further because surprise, surprise, it is not as straightforward as we may assume. There are basically two versions of success. There's objective success and there is
subjective success. Objective success is the visible ledger, the part that I guess other people can verify without having to know you as a person. The salary figure, the job title, the degree, accolades, bestseller list magazine covers. It's something that we can see, count, compare, and often reward through admiration, respect, fame, those kinds of things. Think of objective markers as, I guess, social currency that signal value, but also signal something else. Talent, maybe hard work, passion, motivation. They essentially offer what we call a mental heuristic.
We assume someone who has success, someone who has things on the objective ledger that makes them successful must therefore contain another thing about themselves, a special secret trait that has gotten them there, whether that is true or not. So those markers definitely serve a visual purpose. They serve a purpose in general, but by themselves, you know, objective success doesn't necessarily mean fulfillment unless there is something more emotional and spiritual attached to, you know, what you have achieved and what you have done. I know people who have been on the Forbes 30 under 30 list, who have multi-million dollar businesses who have done incredible things. They have been on this podcast before and outly they appear very successful, but have
revealed, you know, privately to me, how miserable they are because they have objective success without also accounting for the second side of it, subjective success. So subjective success focuses on how you truly feel about and within your life, regardless of, I guess, appearances or accolades. So subjective success, if you want to experience it, has a couple of layers. The first is hedonic well-being. So basically the short-term evaluation of your state of mind or how happy we feel in the moment. you can have a lot of objective success but experience very little day-to-day pleasure because you are really
busy you are really burnt out you are lonely and you are unhappy so there has to be a level of hedonic well-being and then also eutomonic well-being this is the deepest sense that your life is aligned with your values aligned with your potential you are in an expansive state as a human being this element of success is not, it's not optional, right? To have a successful life, your life also has to have your goals, your achievements have to have personal significance. And yes, accolades may be a part of that, but crucially, they cannot be all of it. And now most of us have been trained to optimize the objective metrics of success and just kind of hope the subjective side kind of takes care of that. care of itself. Like we kind of just hope that it will fall into place and like we'll fall in love
with the thing that brings us money. We'll fall in love with the thing that brings us praise and admiration. But it really works that way. Study after study finds that objective metrics of success don't correlate to greater well-being. It's the subjective ones that do. So money, for example, may make you slightly happier, but only up to a point. You know, you may have heard about this famous study that $100,000 is like the threshold where any more money after that won't actually help your well-being. I think nowadays, isn't this crazy? Like the new figure is $250,000. The same goes with achievements and accolades. You know, I always think about these people who, like, famous people who have Grammys and Oscars and Egotts and whatever it is and how, is that
the thing that actually has made them a happy individual? Is that the thing that really matters? And I think a lot of them would say, probably not. The thing that mattered to them was relationships, was getting to fine-tune a craft, was creativity. And whatever that is for you, if that element is incomplete, you will be as well. So if you want to be successful, you have to have the combination of objective and subjective success. And you have to be able to care about the goal beyond the visuals or what it means for others. Now this is how we can understand this further. We can understand this further using something known as self-determination theory. This is one of the most famous psychological theories there is. I am sorry to my psychology students out there. I know you are sick of hearing about this, but it has to be talked about. It was first
proposed in the 1980s and the basic principle of SDT is basically that as humans, we function best we find success when three basic psychological needs are met. Autonomy, competence, and relatedness. When each of these is achieved, success is also achieved. And it's quite formulaic. It's not necessarily simple. So let's break down these components. The first is autonomy.
If you want to be successful, your goals have to be yours to begin with. They're not something that was put on to you. you, something that you feel pressured to do. There has to be a genuine, independent love for the thing. A simple way to test this is to take any major goal you have right now. Anything that you think will make you successful and finish this sentence for me. I chose this because. I choose to do this. I choose to pursue this because and then answer that question. If it ends with because it will look impressive because my parents expect it because I want to prove people wrong because I should. That is a sign that your motive is being driven from the outside. And I get, I get it.
I get that sometimes when you really truly want to get to a certain position in whatever area that is, there may be certain hurdles you have to jump through that don't immediately align with what you want success to feel like. You know, sometimes you do hard work because you do need to impress people to get to where you want to go or because you don't. need a certain amount of money to pursue a dream of yours. But at the end of the day, the outcome you envision way down the line, why does that specific outcome strike a nerve for you? If you want to be successful, you have to know why and you have to be clear on that. So the next part of the formula is competence. Competence is the feeling of getting better at something that matters
to you. It is the moment that you notice, oh my God, this thing that used to take me an hour, now only takes me 50 minutes or like, wow, like my third draft of this novel is really starting to say what I wanted to say or like I can run that distance I used to think was impossible. It's basically the intersection of challenge and skill. We call it the goalie lock zone. You need to be focused on a task or a goal that's not so easy that you might drift away or find it boring, but not so hard that you are paralyzed by fear and don't know what your next step might be. It's also what we might call the flow state, where you just feel aligned with your goal. You feel that it's not too difficult.
You're engaged in it. You're wanting to learn. You're wanting to push forward. You know, to achieve success, you need to also be pursuing competence. You need to be giving your brain a target, something to get better at. This is another defining feature of successful outliers in this world. they do not have vague ambitions. They give their brain something specific.
They give their mind, their soul, their body, something specific to work towards. You know, they don't just say, I want to be more creative, or I want to get rich, I want to get in shape. They have a specific vision that they can track their effort towards. And they then amend their efforts. They get better through the process. They also feel a personal sense of drive towards
that thing, that is being fueled by competence. Now, the final element to this equation, to this theory of what makes somebody successful, what makes somebody feel successful, is relatedness. This is the ability to experience a sense of belonging or connection with other people through the pursuit of your goal. It is the difference between numbers on a dashboard and work that feels really human. A recent Canadian study, looking at over 5,000 people, replicated a finding that has been spoken about for years. The happiest people, the most successful people, the people who say, I've had a successful life. The thing that they all have in common is good, long-term, meaningful relationships.
Even when we hold, you know, even when we control for money and for accolades. If you want to be successful, you cannot operate in isolation. You cannot skimp on relationships. look at your goals again, look at what you want one in your life and ask who actually benefits from this. If you can't name a single person other than yourself, your success is never going to feel, it's never going to have any depth to it. You're always going to feel lacking. It's this strange balance, right? Intrinsic motivation requires us to care deeply for ourselves first and to pursue something because we genuinely love it, but relatedness asks for that not to be the only thing
that you care about. That kind of point of balance that like knife's edge is where successful people live. At least that's what the theory says. I can think of a few people who aren't necessarily doing that. But that's what the theory says. They think not just about themselves, but how it's going to help or impact others. Okay, let's now turn towards the specific habits of successful people that fall into this formula. What a successful, smart people, the people we admire doing that we are not doing, and how can we take what they know and implement it in our own lives to find our own version of success?
That is what we're going to talk about next. Stay tuned. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator of available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe
that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2% that's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And Rule 2, never mess with her friends either. We always say that, trust your girlfriends.
I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed.
I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the hard way and listen now. The habits of successful people that show up again and again in the research are honestly kind of boring. They're kind of simple. Dare I say that is why they work.
Now, a quick caveat here, I have to acknowledge that there are some theories out there that habits, these things we're going to talk about, may only account for like 20% of success. You could do all these things and maybe still not find what you're looking for. Another 20% is raw talent, but the final remainder of the equation of what makes somebody successful is just luck and its circumstances and its context. That is what one theory is on this. And there is a very famous book on this. It's called Outliers by Malcolm Gladwell that discusses this theory.
And his argument basically is that success isn't about how smart you are. It isn't about how hardworking you are. It's about where you come from, where you're born, who helps you and the systems that you're embedded in. You know, for example, Bill Gates, I don't know if you know this, but he had early access to computers. Purely because his high school was one of like three or four high school. in the United States with computers. So way before anybody else had access to these machines, he had thousands of hours of practice before anyone else started.
And he was also born in 1955. Like he reached adulthood just as like the personal computer revolution was beginning. Somebody who was born in 1980 like didn't have that advantage. Success is a whole lot of luck. But I don't find that discouraging because I, I truly believe all of us have a special talent for something. All of us have something we know just a little bit more about than others or have had early experiences with like Bill Gates that we can take and make into something amazing.
You need luck to be successful, yes, but you equally need habits. You need the full 100%. You know, if you leave out the behaviors and the actions, you won't reach a goal no matter how much is stacked in your favor. You know, think about Bill Gates. Yes, he had all these great things. A lot of people who have success have all these early advantages, but they could have also just done nothing with it. You have advantages that you don't know about yet until you act on them.
So as much as there is a theory that habits don't matter, they 100%. Do they are the thing that really pushes people over the line? With that in mind, here are the five standout ones that the psychology and the research says that successful people have. number one successful people fail a lot and failure is inbuilt into their creative and their into the creative process and their pursuit you know we often only see the perfect celebration photos the awards the medals you don't see failed assignments emails that never got a response dream deals that fell through this is the reality of every successful people every successful person
And I was going to say many, it's every. Realistically, the majority of the time spent working towards a goal or a dream is spent on countless iterations of the same idea, which never come out fully developed. Or countless attempts that just don't hit a target. Ask any person you admire, they all have a story of someone who said, someone who told them like, you know, it's pointless. what you're doing is pointless.
You're going to fail. That's a really bad idea. Literally every single person has that story. My favorite one is Meryl Streep. You know when she auditioned for King Kong, the director called her ugly in Italian, not knowing that she spoke Italian, and she didn't get the part.
Like, the literal Meryl Streep, Miranda Priestley, the icon, she was rejected. For all intents and purposes, like she failed. And so when you, fail. When you are rejected, that puts you in the same camp as her. That puts you one more failure closer to your dream. And the thing is, if she'd stopped at that first plateau or that first hurdle, she wouldn't be the success she is now. And she wouldn't have become what she is.
Having a resilience and a resistance to failure is a personality attribute that every successful person has in common and it's also a habit that you can you know strengthen in yourself secondly successful people know the value of working in silence such that outward forces don't interrupt their creative process or their their thought process i think we live in a little bit of like a share first act later culture but there is this curious thing psychologists noticed about that which is that when you tell people about your goals or about your dreams before you have acted on them, often that can mean that you essentially don't feel the need to go through with it anymore. I talked about this in your year for doing less and achieving more in that episode, but essentially telling people your goals
symbolizes the kind of person you are, which means that you don't have to act on those goals in the meantime. We get the recognition that we want. We get the sense that we are acting out the person we want to be by simply talking about what we want to do without actually doing it. Now, obviously, some people don't operate this way. Sometimes public acknowledgement can help you work harder when you feel like there is a standard you need to reach or a promise you need to fulfill. And sometimes people announce their goals as a way of accountability so they're more likely to follow through. The follow through though has to be crucial. You know, you have to be able to act on your goals and work on them without praise, without recognition, without visibility. I just think that the ability
to work silently makes you and your ambitions more intimate with each other, if that makes sense. Like, you have less fear around making mistakes because you're not doing them publicly. You have more room for experimentation early on, which is like, you know, the crucial part of any success story is, again, the failure at the beginning, the risk at the beginning. You get to grow without projecting embarrassment onto your efforts, without feeling embarrassed because people are watching, which can stop you from doing anything in the first place. So there will be time to share, take a slip out of the successful admirable people's books and just let your work mature first. Thirdly, successful individuals typically follow the 80-20 rule.
This is also known as the Pareto principle, which basically says that 80% of consequences come from 20% of causes or actions. Fancy way of saying a small part of what you do, a small part of how you act, creates most of the results. Now, if you're a perfectionist like myself, you may hate to hear this. We have this habit of like obsessing over 100% of every single detail. But in reality, a lot of successful people make sacrifices and they just satisfy requirements rather than perfecting them. They make things good enough on purpose. Not sloppy, not bad, but good enough. They understand the cost of obsessing over details that other people may not even appreciate.
The 20% is their focus. That is where they know they will see the most impact on the end result. And in practice, that looks like choosing and protecting the highest leverage pieces, before you start. If that's an essay, it is the main argument and structure, not the synonyms and the spacing. If it is studying for an exam, it is the high yield concepts and your retrieval practice, not re-highlighting every single paragraph. If it is, I don't know, a movie or a movie script, it is the relatable, intricate, cool character, not, again, not like the small, minute things that people are going to flip over, not how your script is structured or how it looks
visually on a page. Decide what must be true for your vision to work. What are the crucial three, four elements that need to be great and let that drive your effort. This also means deciding ahead of time what done will look like for you and what that will mean for you. and then respect that finished boundary. When will I be okay with, you know, putting this project or putting this desire out into the world? When will I let it be seen?
Is there a part of me that's just so afraid of judgment or embarrassment that no matter how much work I do on this, I will never allow it to be visible because I'm afraid. You have to find a way to also circumvent that deep fear as well. check in with yourself on whether this is good enough, whether the extra hour will actually change the outcome or just soothe your anxiety, whether the extra month will actually improve upon your goal or make you more successful or whether, again, it's just a form of self-protection. And I think this allows you not only to avoid burnout through additional labor and mental fatigue, but also, you know, be realistic about what's beneficial and what's
superfluous to your goals and prioritize your time in a way that it's going to be spent well and better. The cliche throughout this all, the cliche of this specific tip is basically working smarter, not harder. That is what successful people do. We are up to our fourth tip and this one is actually, this one's my favorite. This is the one that I rely on the most. It is my favorite habit of all. And that is that successful people learn how to enjoy hard work. Here is this like the sneaky superpower. Nobody probably taught you in school. You can actually condition your brain to find hard work and effort rewarding in its own right. Robert Eisenberger, he called this concept, learnt industriousness, it basically means that when your effort repeatedly leads to a meaningful reward,
the effort itself begins to feel good, maybe even fun and enjoyable. And that reward, crucially, doesn't need to be external. It doesn't need to be objective success. It doesn't need to be external praise or money or fame or whatever. It can just be enjoyment, satisfaction, progress or competence, like we spoke about. before. Basically, fall in love with what it feels like to get better and focus on the parts of the process that you really enjoy and that you find romantic. Learned industriousness is basically just for me romanticizing hard work until the work doesn't feel hard. When I was at university, for example, the way I got good at studying is that I really enjoyed and I romanticized late
nights at the library. It made me fall in love with the process and with the hard work because there was some like secondary satisfaction in it. So I rarely studied before midday. I really studied before 5 p.m. because I just found that that sensation of like, oh, it was almost like the narrative around like working hard and working hard at night and it's dark and like it's whimsical. Not whimsical. It's like it's romantic and it's like, I don't know, academic. Like that allowed me to experience learned industriousness. The work itself was something I fell in love with. It might be that you're really struggling to, you know, figure out a problem at work. And when you finally figure it out, there is this huge sense of relief so that next time, you know, you feel more
patient, you feel more willing to tackle the next difficult problem. It might feel like changing your environment so that, you know, going to a we work, going to like, you know, going to like, like a co-working space so you feel the romance and like the inspiration of being around other people who are working hard it may be setting up rewards for certain hurdles you know you have to cross certain things you know you have to do falling in love with reaching your limit and then that becoming your new base point and I know that sounds very cerebral and very like up in the air it's a feeling that you need to learn how to chase though because like wherever you are whatever you're doing, whatever your goal is, like there's going to become a point where it's just going to suck
耐心地，你会觉得自己更有意愿去攻克下一个难题。这可能就像是改变你的环境，比如，去一个WeWork，去一个，你知道的，去一个类似共享办公空间的地方，这样你就能感受到被其他努力工作的人环绕的浪漫感和灵感；这可能是为某些跨越不顺的坎、某些你知道必须完成的事情设置奖励；爱上达到极限的感觉，然后让那成为你的新起点。我知道这听起来非常理性、非常虚幻，但这是你需要学会去追求的一种感觉，因为无论你在哪里，无论你在做什么，无论你的目标是什么，总会有一个时刻，事情会变得一团糟，
and it's going to be hard and you're not going to see results and blah, blah, blah, like there is always going to be the dip where you're not seeing outcomes anymore. So when you cannot rely on the outcomes to reinforce your behavior, rely on the behavior to reinforce your behavior because you enjoy it just intrinsically. When you can hack that, when you can feel, that like I genuinely believe like you can achieve do be literally anything you want to be. Okay, we're going to take one more teeny tiny break and then when we return I have tip number five plus just like some very simple advice for you but important advice on how to include subjective success in your ambitions and in your dreams. So stay with us.
而且会变得很艰难，你可能看不到任何成果，诸如此类。总会有这样一个低谷期，你再也看不到任何结果。所以，当你无法依靠结果来强化你的行为时，去依靠行为本身来强化你的行为，因为你发自内心地享受它。当你能破解这一点时，当你能感受到这一点时——我真的相信你可以成就、成为字面意义上任何你想成为的人。好吧，我们再休息一会儿，然后回来时，我将分享第五条建议，以及一些非常简单但对你如何将主观成功融入雄心与梦想至关重要的建议。所以，请继续收听。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析这个奇怪现代世界中心理坚韧、健身和建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾以为种子油本身就具有炎性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends...
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。这就是iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上的《2%》（T-W-O-Persent）。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。法则一，千万别惹乡下女孩。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。法则二，也千万别惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在新一季的《女朋友们》中……
Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by her. a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
天哪，这居然是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的诈骗犯约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。于是她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼去吧。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到应有的惩罚。收听《女朋友们：相信我，宝贝》，就在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（揉捏）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利希（Alex English）。每一集里，我们都会挑选一个时刻，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着弄清楚我们是如何挺过来的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed Correct. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
其中包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的访谈，畅谈80年代的快克可卡因。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不只是因为快克。我随时准备在任何一天聊聊快克，只是为了让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们第二集讨论快克了。所以我开始发现这里有一条贯穿线。我们桌上现在还有艾滋病。谢谢你把话说完。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台上收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《用难的方式去学习》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们的主持人，也是你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将把自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多出色嘉宾的对话带给大家。
I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
我在跟特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）交谈。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入这场追逐，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐，甚至不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
生活变成了关于胜利与失败。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯廷·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。你觉得在这个世上做个好人重要吗？你做个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。这也是两个不同信任层面的问题。我希望你们能真正地去做一个好人。
Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. We have made it finally to tip number five. Number five, drumroll plays successful people structure their environments to make focusing easier. They understand the importance of environmental cues and environmental productivity. And let me ask you this question. How much laziness, procrastination, boredom, do you think comes down to simply the fact that your environment is stacked against you, that your phone is next to you all the time, that you're working somewhere with distractions. We romanticize willpower, but we also know that the context we're in, the environment we're in plays a huge role in our attention, our focus, our drive,
加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，我们将在我的新播客《用难的方式去学习》中进行关于疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用，搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。我们终于迎来了第五条建议。第五条，敲鼓声响起。成功人士会构建他们的环境，以使专注变得更加容易。他们理解环境线索和环境生产力的重要性。让我问你这个问题。你认为有多少懒惰、拖延和无聊，归根结底只是因为你的环境对你不利，你的手机一直放在你身边，你工作的地方充满干扰。我们总是将意志力浪漫化，但我们也知道，我们所处的背景、我们所处的环境在我们的注意力、专注力和驱动力中扮演着巨大的角色，
habits piggyback on our environmental cues. in behavioral science literature. This is referred to as choice architecture. It's basically the act of deliberately crafting an environment that makes the decisions you want to make easier and the decisions you don't want to make or the behaviors you don't want to do harder without actually forcing you to pursue a specific outcome. Basically, the most simplest example, if you want to, I don't know, I'm trying to think of a really basic one. If there is water by your bedside table and a soda in the fridge, you're going to drink the water first if you're really thirsty.
习惯依赖于我们的环境线索。在行为科学文献中，这被称为选择架构。这基本上就是刻意打造一个环境的行为，让你想要做出的决定变得更容易，而让你不想做出的决定或不想做的行为变得更难，同时又不会强迫你追求某个特定的结果。基本上，最简单的例子，如果你想——我不知道，我正在努力想一个非常基础的例子。如果你的床头柜旁有一瓶水，而冰箱里有一罐苏打水，如果你真的很渴，你首先会喝水。
Like, it's just simple, right? It's just you've just queued it. If your phone is four inches from your hand, congratulations. You have created choice architecture. You have created an environment where you have built a phone checking habit because it is the path of least resistance. If your desk on the other hand is a single purpose zone, your apps are blocked. for 60 minutes you have a no phone space and a go phone space like that helps you break unhelpful habits by focusing on the environment and how you can manipulate it to help yourself keep it just super simple give spaces one job have a designated deep workspace have a designated workspace do not do homework
就像这样，很简单，对吧？你只是给它设置了线索。如果你的手机离你的手只有四英寸，恭喜你。你已经创造了一个选择架构。你创造了一个让你养成查看手机习惯的环境，因为这是阻力最小的路径。另一方面，如果你的桌子是一个单一用途的区，你的应用程序被屏蔽了60分钟，你有一个无手机空间和一个有手机空间，就像这样，通过关注环境以及如何操纵环境来帮助自己，这能帮你打破无益的习惯，保持超级简单：给空间赋予单一的任务，有一个专门的深度工作区，有一个专门的工作区，不要在床上做作业，
do not do work work do not do whatever it is on your phone in bed like that is your rest space or don't bring your phone in bed and only use it in your living room. Another big one, do not eat lunch at your desk. Trust me on this one. A 2021 study showed indications that it actually makes you less productive, even if you imagine, even if you believe it is saving you time. You know, if you're wanting to read more and stop scrolling before bed, pick an interesting book, put it on your pillow. If you want to learn the guitar, put the stand right next to your sofa or right next to the place where you're going to sit down and maybe even experience the most boredom throughout the day so that, you know, the alternative is right there. You don't have to go looking for it.
不要在床上工作，不要在床上用手机做任何事情——那是你的休息空间，或者不要把手机带到床上，只在起居室使用它。另一个重要的事情是，不要在办公桌前吃午饭。相信我这一点。2021年的一项研究表明，这实际上会让你效率降低，即使你想象中、即使你坚信它为你节省了时间。你知道的，如果你想在睡前读更多书并停止刷手机，挑一本有趣的书，把它放在你的枕头上。如果你想学吉他，把吉他支架放在你的沙发旁边，或者放在你坐下来、可能一天中最觉得无聊的地方旁边，这样，你知道的，替代方案就在触手可及的地方。你不必四处寻找。
There is literally no friction between you and the decision or the path that you most want to take. When you make these small adjustments to your environment, you know, it turns your desired choices into habits simply by allowing or increasing repetition through the reduction of pain points between you and your desired behavior and therefore you and your desired goals. Okay, those are my five tips that I have gathered from the research, gathered from investigating this. Crucially, though, we have to return to this idea that a through line throughout all of this is that if you want success, you have to actually have an identity beyond success. And I know that sounds counterintuitive, but the danger of a narrow status-centered identity is that you create contingent self-worth. you only feel worthy when you're winning.
在你和你想做的决定或路径之间，实际上没有任何摩擦。当你对环境进行这些微小的调整时，你知道的，它通过减少你和期望行为之间的痛点从而增加重复性，进而将你期望的选择变成了习惯，因此也拉近了你与期望目标的距离。好了，这些是我从研究和调查中收集到的五个建议。不过至关重要的是，我们必须回到这个观点，即贯穿这一切的一条核心主线是：如果你想要成功，你必须拥有超越成功的身份认同。我知道这听起来有违直觉，但狭隘的、以地位为中心的身份认同的危险在于，你会创造出带有条件的自我价值感。只有当你赢了的时候，你才觉得自己有价值。
You only feel worthy when the singular goal that you have focused on is being achieved. And often I describe it as like having a toxic boyfriend or a toxic girlfriend. You know, when things are going good, it's absolutely amazing. When things are going bad, it's horrendous because you have nothing else to rely on. So take all these tips, do with them what you will, but make sure that you have an identity that is wide enough to contain all versions of yourself. be as focused as you need to be lock in full in love with the hard work also have a hobby have an interest because that will diversify your sense of self therefore making it stronger and this could
只有当你一直专注的单一目标得以实现时，你才觉得自己有价值。我经常把它形容为拥有一个有毒的男友或有毒的女友。你知道的，当事情顺利时，感觉绝对棒极了。当事情不顺利时，简直糟透了，因为你无可依赖。所以，吸收所有这些建议，随你如何运用，但请确保你拥有一个足够广阔、能够容纳你自己所有版本的身份认同。尽你所需地专注于此，全身心地投入到艰苦的工作中，但同时也要有一个爱好、一个兴趣，因为这会使你的自我意识更加多元化，从而使其变得更加强大，这可以
literally be anything volunteering coloring cooking for your friends you know there is this idea and and i think even sometimes like i've i've probably promoted it by accident but like there's this idea that if you want something you have to be so focused on it that you've that you've live, breathe, become the blood of that thing. But, you know, these other things are not distractions. They're actually necessary cushioning for the rest of your life, necessary so that you can stay whole and rounded rather than this like machine that is all about output and goals. I think the paradoxes and the important paradoxes is that pouring into your wider identity often improves the traditional markers of success as well. With less fear riding on each outcome, you take smarter
字面意义上是任何事情：做志愿者、填色、为朋友做饭。你知道的，有一种观点——而且我认为有时甚至连我自己可能都不小心推广了这种观点——那就是如果你想要某样东西，你必须对它高度专注，以至于你生活、呼吸、融入了那个东西的血液。但是，你知道的，这些其他事情并不是干扰。它们实际上是你生活的其余部分的必要缓冲，是必要的，这样你才能保持完整和全面，而不是成为一个只关乎产出和目标的机器。我认为其中的悖论、也是重要的悖论在于，倾注于你更广泛的身份认同通常也会提升传统的成功标志。由于每个结果所承载的恐惧减少了，你会做出更明智的
risks, you bounce back faster, you experiment more freely. And a last reminder, this is my last one, I promise, before I wrap up this episode is that just remember people find success at all ages. There is this huge, massive, major emphasis on finding success young and early so that you can ride the highs for longer so that you can prove yourself. I don't want any of us believing that you know, your 20s are the only decade where you can really do something or that you're running out of time because you haven't done it yet. You have so much time. You are not behind. Whatever age you are. And I literally mean whatever age you are, you could be 99. There is someone who has found their success older than you are now. And many, many others,
风险决策，你会更快地恢复过来，你会更自由地进行实验。最后一个提醒，这是我的最后一个提醒，我保证，在结束这一集之前，请记住人们在各个年龄段都能取得成功。社会上有一种巨大、海量、主要倾向，那就是强调趁年轻、趁早取得成功，这样你就可以享受更长时间的高光时刻，这样你就可以证明自己。我不希望我们任何人相信，你知道的，你的20多岁是你真正能做点什么的唯一十年，或者因为你还没做到而时间已经不多了。你还有大把的时间。你并没有落后。无论你多大年龄。我字面意思是无论你多大年龄，哪怕你99岁。也有人在比你现在更大的年龄取得了成功。还有许许多多的人，
Other than that, have created their own version of success that is not glamorous, but was deeply meaningful for them at any age, any stage, any point in their life. So you are not behind. Timelines are literally, I will die on this hill. They are literally a social fiction. And real life will peak in all different places for different reasons. So if you are still sampling in your 20s and you're experimenting and you're unsure what objective or subjective success even looks like for you,
除此之外，他们都以各自的年龄、各自的阶段、各自人生的任何节点，创造出了属于他们自己的、虽然并不光鲜亮丽但对他们而言意义重大的成功版本。所以你并没有落后。时间线简直——我将为这个观点至死方休——时间线简直就是一个社会虚构。而且现实生活会出于不同的原因在不同的地方达到巅峰。所以如果你在20多岁时仍在尝试，还在进行实验，甚至不确定客观或主观的成功对你来说究竟是什么样子的，
I actually think that's an incredible thing. That means you have even more to discover. You have a blank slate in front of you that a lot of individuals would be envious of. So as much as we have definitely highlighted and emphasized a lot of the sexy, glamorous examples of success. And as much as people love a young success story and they're in our face all the time, again, you have time. you can change at any minute if you are focusing on the 20% if you are leveraging talent leveraging context and then also doing the work so that when the opportunity arrives not if when it arrives like you are going to be so ready you're going to have everything you need in your toolkit to just be like
我实际上认为这是一件了不起的事情。这意味着你有更多的东西去探索。你的面前有一张许多人都会羡慕的白纸。因此，尽管我们确实强调并突出了许多性感、光鲜亮丽的成功案例，尽管人们总是喜欢年轻成功的的故事并且它们天天在我们眼前晃悠，但再次强调，你还有时间。如果你专注于那20%，如果你在利用天赋、利用背景，然后同时也在努力工作，以便当机会来临时——不是如果，而是当机会来临时——你将准备得如此充分，你的工具箱里将拥有一切所需，然后你就可以说：
cool I'm going to hit the ground running I'm going to fail and I'm going to know that that is like failure is on my to do list I'm going to you know work in silence I'm going to follow the 80-20 rule. I'm going to I'm going to follow the learned industrious rule and I'm going to just like create the environments that I need to succeed. Like that is what you're going to be ready to do. So I'm excited for each and every one of you. That is all for me today. If you have made it this far, I want you to answer in the comments for me this question. What is your favorite success story? Who is a traditional, untraditionally successful person that you admire? and why is that?
“酷，我要大干一场，我要经历失败，而且我知道失败就在我的待办清单上，我要在沉默中工作，我要遵循二八定律，我要遵循习得的勤奋法则，我要创造我成功所需的环境。”就像，这就是你将准备好去做的事情。所以我为你们每个人感到兴奋。这就是我今天的全部内容。如果你听到了这里，我希望你在评论区回答我这个问题：你最喜欢的成功故事是什么？谁是你所崇拜的传统意义上或非传统意义上成功的人？为什么？
I want to hear your thoughts in the comments below. As always, thank you to our researcher Libby Colbert for her wonderful, excellent contributions to this episode. She is a Star. Make sure that you're following us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcasts. And if you have an episode suggestion, something we haven't covered yet, feel free to email us, The Psychology of Your 20s at gmail.com or send me a DM. I would absolutely love to hear from you. but until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself,
我迫想在下方的评论区听到你们的想法。一如既往，感谢我们的研究员莉比·科尔伯特（Libby Colbert）对本期节目的精彩、卓越贡献。她是个明星。请确保在Instagram上关注我们，账号是That Psychology Podcasts。如果你有节目建议，有我们尚未涵盖的内容，欢迎给我们发邮件：The Psychology of Your 20s at gmail.com，或者给我发私信。我绝对非常渴望听到你们的声音。但直到下一次，保重，保持善良，对自己温柔一点，
and as always, we will talk very, very soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
一如既往，我们很快就会再聊。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。